did you test the point what point did
you choose one one four and four okay so
four four by the way you might notice
I've put some coordinates here not
because you necessarily have to but it
just gives me a sense of where I can
test sort of inside or outside so if I
put in four four which that means it's
somewhere over here okay if I throw that
into the left-hand side here I'm getting
the absolute value of 4 times 4 which is
16 is the absolute value 16 satisfy this
inequality cool it is so at the very
least I know over here is okay right now
that's the in one way to say it that's
the outside of that branch of the
hyperbola right so it stands to reason
could I do the rest of the outsides as
well right now most of you have shaded
that have you done that by testing more
points or did you think about something
that led you to that conclusion who
tested more points you test them on
points you like yep cool I am playing it
safe I have like I don't trust myself
which is totally fine because then I
think that does get you from 7 to 10
yeah I actually checked I'm confident
you guys did not what made you think
that yeah I can do these good good good
so these two methods they complement
each other right this is like yes I can
brute-force this and make sure I can
take everything off but this way is to
say hold on a second if I see absolute
values what that should indicate to me
now that I'm in real number land are you
ok with that
like I don't have any more complex
numbers I have to worry about so in real
number land
I can now think about evaluators don't
worry about positive negatives just
worry about is your number big or is it
small okay and you know these numbers
over here what am I going to have over
here a point like this might be three
negative three yeah my numbers forget
about the sign the numbers are getting
big as I go over here just like they got
big up here right and you can extend the
same argument my numbers are just
getting bigger over here don't worry
about the sign my numbers are just
getting bigger over here don't worry
about this side
okay so it does so happen good job you
can be confident back yourself but do be
cautious I mean very this is a common
example over here right have you guys
encountered this inequality before have
you seen it it's a pretty famous example
because it breaks you know you're just
like you're easy pattern recognition
if for example I told you that this part
here would lead me to shade this part
over here if I extended my logic over
here just like I might think I might be
tempted to think it's down here okay
because it's like the inside and the
outside these branches divided into just
two parts but you'd be wrong it's this
part and there's two ways that you can
think about this number one this graph
has a discontinuity right where's the
discontinuity x equals zero very good
also has its continuity why cause your
but that's not interesting to me here x
equals zero zero actually breaks this up
there's an invisible wall there right so
you know how I said before ah it kind of
looks like let me draw it one more time
sorry this board is such a mess it looks
like there's an inside and an outside
right it looks like that but in fact
there is not this asymptote also breaks
things up okay the other way to think
about it of course is if you have wires
the subject then generally speaking Y is
greater than means above whatever it is
you've drawn right so Y is greater than
2x minus 1 2 X minus 1 what's that
bigger it's gonna be above this guy
don't even need to test a point I've
already got it in a nice neat form okay
all right how are you feeling your brain
okay you content now I have one last
thing to raise with you because we kind
of skipped over it we said it was fine
and I promise you I would you know
actually push me to see if you
understood it all of this is on the
assumption that you trust me about this
line here right you've had to trust me
up until this point I mean Justin you
had sort of like a my spider sense is
tingling I think it's okay but how could
you prove that you can break apart an
absolute value in two or I should say at
this point a modulus how can I prove
that I can separate that modulus into
its component parts I'm just going to
let you think while I make myself some
space
this is harder than it looks isn't it
something to do with rotation
that's an interesting pot anyway else
I'm not gonna gratify yet we're saying
yes that's of course that's right I want
you to think about rotation by the way
is not a bad instinct because in complex
numbers you know when you multiply by a
complex number
like say I write what that means is
rotation it through whatever your
argument is and it also means you scale
by whatever your modulus is right so
that's not a bad way of thinking there
is a problem with thinking about a hero
and I'll let you think about it for a
second I thought about rotation - the
first time I met questions like this
right I thought ooh is I times something
like this just you know rotate it Payan
- right when you do with vectors that
does happen okay but I want to explain
why that happens if I have some numbers
here like we introduced before right and
I multiply through by I watch what
happens okay what are you gonna get here
I X and what happens here Y like so now
this is a little bit weird because now
my real and imaginary components have
kinda swapped right so I actually am
gonna write this in the proper order
real first an imaginary second here's my
real part like so here's my imaginary
part so if my X plus iy was here there's
my X and that distance there would be Y
okay there's Z what does this guy look
like well I'm going to take this
distance here and the real component
will be now over there so there's my Y
over there and then here this X is now
the imaginary component so I'm gonna go
up like so okay so can you see that now
if I draw in the vectors from the origin
it becomes very clear there's my right
angle are you okay with that right now
why is it that this is not the same as
this it is not
just multiplication by or rotation
rather by a 90 degrees pay on to the
reason why is this is not the complex
number you started with right that's not
X plus iy that's that's a real number
right what's happening with that the
rules are slightly different now here's
the way I think which is nice which in
some ways there's a bit like what you
did so it's like I'm just going to brute
force my way through this brute-force
ways I think you don't want to do in
exams because you're not have time for
it but it is something you want to do to
prove that things are true for yourself
right let me get right back to like a
general case right if I've got two
complex numbers oh sorry
let's keep them together in there what I
want to try and prove is that this is
equal to what happens if you take those
moduli separately and then multiply okay
so I'm saying here I'm trying to suggest
that the modulus of the product equals
the product of the moduli are you ok
with that
ok so how would I do this well mm-hmm
have a look at this guy if I give these
guys some names like say let's call this
a plus I B and C plus I D that's a
pretty common way to break this up okay
well I know what the modulus is like I
have a formula for this right by
definition through I've rubbed it off
unfortunately through Pythagoras what is
this guy here square root of thank you
very much and unlike before you're like
no I'm confident you can prove this
country
soup easy if you just wrote yourself a
right angle you're fine right what about
this guy C squared plus d squared okay
don't forget this is a complex number
but a B C and D what kinds of numbers
are they they're all real aren't they
okay so therefore because these are all
real numbers they play by the rules that
real numbers do I can combine these
square roots like I did before I'm gonna
get this mmm it's a little bit messy but
it's not hard that's a B are you content
with that and it's not much more you can
do with that I've expanded everything
out this is the final point okay I've
started from this point here and then I
have used my knowledge of complex
numbers in majalaya what have you now
let's see what happens if I
from up here I need more space can you
write that out for me write out the the
modulus rather of z1 z2 and I want you
to see being that we've just provided a
definition for z1 this guy and a
definition for z2 this guy can you
multiply through first multiply those
complex numbers together and then see
what happens when you take the modules
I'll give you a little bit of head start
yeah there
hmm okay how do you feel now do you feel
better I hope there's a part of you it's
like oh now I don't just accept that
this is true now that I know that this
is true I haven't even finished it I'm
like I've gone far enough
like I'm content with that okay now can
I just make one last sort of conclusion
by bringing a parallel from this to when
you first learn how to differentiate
what was that very first thing we taught
you to do remember within
differentiation I'll give you a clue it
starts with this what have we done we
learned limits so that we could do
differentiation by first principles
right and you guys are like oh man
especially if you've ever encountered
differentiation before you like but I
know rules why can't I just like use
rules instead of this awful ten times
longer way of doing things right and the
answer is not because you were apart
from like once in a very early
assessment not because we're gonna
require this particular skill of you we
want you to have a kind of way of
thinking that like I don't know if this
is true you know what I can go back to
something earlier something I can rest
on this is just rise over run isn't it
just as gradient I can know something
that's confident and then build off of
that and say yes I have a conclusion
that I know his trust word does that
make sense so if you get a question like
this you don't obviously need to do any
of this but now that's part of your
mental vocabulary for how you can move
through this and why you know you can
separate that out into its pieces okay
does anyone have any questions